also i mean i i put up a satirical uh
thing on instagram the other day
they take it down we send it to our
friend in vc it's a joke i said i'm
osama bin laden i'm not dead
i'm i'm get i'm getting to an energy
drink and we're entering the first round
of fundraising
and it's called bomb energy and you know
i did a lot of jokes i said
and um can we pull it up let's read the
email
that instagram took down which is
clearly satirical
and this is why i'm getting frustrated
everyone hates the way i say that word i
say
frustrated but it's frustrated with
capitalism because you would think
capitalism is all these badasses that go
[ __ ] you it makes money
but what it really is is a lot of people
that are [ __ ] and they're
rolling over because 10 people on
twitter get offended at something
i know all these badasses supposedly
these cold heartless capitalists
they're all rolling over uh and
capitulating to like
it used to be like this mob of weird
evangelical soccer moms
that would be like we don't want marilyn
manson performing in
pittsburgh and now
it's like [ __ ] a few thousand people
on twitter that get angry about anything
and these billion dollar corporations
and these ceos worth a hundred million
they just roll the [ __ ] over cause
they're terrified
well what the [ __ ] the point
i mean at the end of the day didn't
stalin just kill these people they had a
problem
to the gulag maybe that's where i
ideologically end up
saying well you know what everyone gets
to go to the gulag
let's pull this email up that we sent to
our friend
who's a friend of ours he's a young kid
in vc
and we said dear frederick my name is
osama bin laden
many people think i am dead that is not
true i'm alive and well
and i'm very excited about the energy
drink space
we have come up with a caffeine-free
antioxidant packed energy drink
called bomb energy which promotes
overall health
while stimulating the consumer in a
sustainable and vital manner
we are beginning to raise capital and
are hoping for a 9 11 launch date
which i had nothing to do with by the
way we are very interested in partnering
with your venture
to take bomb energy to the next level
our slogan
is bomb energy the jews run the world
initial focus groups have been very
responsive to this slogan mind you
many of them have been done in the arab
world we're looking to potentially
soften our messaging
as we take bomb energy
mainstream and that is why we believe
you a squishy bagel face
are the right person to help us in this
endeavor we are committed
to increasing our market share in the
ever expanding market
of health and nutrition we thought this
project would interest you
a little zionist doughboy we look
forward to hearing from you and working
together
and then we say we also have heard
positive things about uh patrick
finnegan hopefully you can connect us
who's a
a venture guy in new york who's on
clubhouse who we knew and then i said
best regards osama ceo of bomb energy
and instagram took this off
i don't know why it's supposedly it's an
algorithm that identifies words
how but there's a lot of words that are
criticizing zionism and i'm making a
joke
so i guess jews or or bin laden
i think it's the bin laden thing it said
when they took it off it said
an association with dangerous groups
right
so i
am just getting a little i'm a little
i'm a little listen
we all know capitalism has this lion's
share of problems
but we never anticipated that one of
them that
would be that the ceos of companies are
too
sensitive and considerate
and that's my issue now it's one of them
i would like people to have health care
and i would like them to afford buying a
house
but i would also like if you're gonna be
a capitalist pig
be one and tell people to shut the [ __ ]
up
go dude the guy's got a certain amount
of followers
he's a comedian it says comedian in the
thing i'm not gonna whine about this the
whole episode because it's boring and we
get it
but they're trying to kick the
weinsteins off and you know me and the
weinsteins are just
deeply in love with each other and
here's what i'll say about the
weinsteins they should
i think they're smart and i think they
should be able to say whatever they want
to say on youtube
i don't care what they're talking about
whether it's the voting or the migration
patterns of bees
or whatever it it doesn't matter to me
and i think they make a lot of sense
when they stick to science and
evolutionary biology because that's what
you do
and i think they should be able to do it
and i want to hear what they have to say
about the vaccine and what they have to
say about ivor mets or whatever the [ __ ]
it is
i i'm not talking about it because i
don't know anything about it
i got the vaccine because i want to go
to london and suck off somebody
with who's uncut who has the with the
when the skin is over the head of the
penis
and i can't do it if i'm in uh
america well i can't i would did it once
it was not for me
but i figured british would be better uh
and then you could have the roast have
the roast on sundays with the peas that
they mash up it's not a great food
country
but they have uh the uh the indians very
good the chicken tikka marsala
my point is this i wasn't like the
vaccine is here
i didn't change my name to a vaccine on
twitter like some mentally deranged
people i know
i got the vaccine because i thought i
would need it to do my job and i would i
will i know
to go anywhere and to do anything but
listen i want to know
about everything and i think it's good
for society when you look at how fast
that labley hypothesis went from a
conspiracy
to a mainstream news where jon stewart
is on colbert saying hey guys
he's saying the exact same thing that
the weinsteins were saying six
[ __ ] months ago to their credit to
brett's credit and to heather hein's
credit
and i have no closer friends than those
two but uh
and i like them they're just a little is
a little sensitive but i think they're
spot on with a lot of that stuff and
they should be able to go into i don't
need to i don't need expertise on
everything that's ever
happened but i think this is this is
their [ __ ] turf
and to get them off youtube is [ __ ] up
but no one cares
so there's gonna need to be an
alternative there's gonna need to be an
alternative to youtube there's gonna
need to be an alternative
um to to a lot of these social media
sites i don't know who's going to do it
or who's going to come up with it but
there's going to be after it's going to
have to be an alternative and it got to
be 20 million
can we get spotify on the phone by the
way can we get them on the phone right
now because i'm a little
i'm a little heated we have the core
daddy girl get 60 million dollars
uh to talk about anal joe rogan gets a
hundred million dollars to talk about
aliens and bigfoot
and tim dillon who is really covering
everything uh gets nothing